in the words of a very jolly man ho ho
ho I ho ho hope you're all having a
happy holiday season and a very Merry
Christmas to my fellows who celebrate
it's been an interesting year for me for
all of us both on and off the channel
but here we are at the end of it guess
we survived another year didn't we but I
know what you've been up late at night
tossing and turning unable to fall
asleep wondering about you've been
curious what games I played this year
and which ones I liked the most so
because you wanted to know so badly I
made this video for you there is no
particular order since I enjoyed all of
these games for various different
reasons but I would be a lying fool if I
didn't start off with the big delicious
truly Holly experience that is the
Legend of Zelda tears of the kingdom and
I know what you're thinking but Bandit
didn't you hate tears of the Kingdom
what in The Season's Greetings are you
doing talking about it here then didn't
you make like three videos criticizing
tears of the
kingdom yes yes I did but it's still a
really fun game I wasted I mean spent
hundreds of hours playing tears of the
Kingdom so of course I enjoyed it I was
itching for a nice new open world uh oh
uh sorry that was actually breath of the
wild footage I was showing there not um
tears of the Kingdom I get them confused
sometimes anyway like I was saying I was
itching for a nice new open World
explorative experience and tears of the
Kingdom scratched me real good so I
recommend it to anyone let it grow you
as a player as you experience just how
it feels to plummet from a sky island
all the way to the ground turning link
into a hen pancake let it immerse you in
its Rich environment that includes a
Coliseum match against five lionels let
the weirdest most Unholy combinations
come to mind as you play around with the
brand new Ultra hand mechanic and let it
cause your adventures to allow you to
soar high above the sky islands let it
scratch you but the latest Zelda game
didn't come out till like may I
think
yeah May that's like half the year gone
so of course I played games before that
and one of these games in particular
also just so happened to be one of the
most impactful games I've ever played in
my life huh it's called outer Wilds it's
one of those games that most people have
heard of at one point or another but
also most people haven't gotten around
to playing
yet and I'll admit I was one of those
people too in fact I bought the game
years ago and tried it out for like 5
minutes and then just let it sit in my
steam Library abandoned and forgotten
about you know like zeldor it has
literal space exploration with different
planets you can seamlessly land on that
each come with their own interconnected
puzzles to solve and quirky lovable
characters and amazing space mechanics
to master or not master if you're like a
certain
someone but most of all a deeply deeply
emotional story that comes out of
nowhere and slaps you good and hard in a
good way I strongly recommend outer
Wilds to anybody who enjoys being
slapped and even if you don't and it's
on sale right now actually it's it's
only 15 bucks I think for the entire
base game or $24 for the base game plus
the DLC which is just as good as the
base game if not even a little bit
better you can even roast marshmallows
over the fire and eat them when they're
cooked just right or you know burn them
directly in the Flames like a psychopath
which is what I did I could go on about
how it saved my life and solved world
hunger but I mean at this point you get
the point also as a side note people who
have played this game love it to bits
and swear to never spoil this game to
new people who have yet to play it which
is why you rarely see discussions about
it online and trust me after you go
through it you'll understand why I am
partially ashamed to admit that I have
delved back into World of Warcraft this
year like a drugie who just can't quit
in my defense I have been playing the
game since its launch way back when in
2004 cuz I'm that old and ever since
then I've never really been able to stay
away for more than like a year or two at
a time which definitely sounds very
healthy but I have been a part of that
Universe for well over half of my life
at this point and I just I just don't
know what I'd do without it damn it but
in the recent expansions blizzard has
actually handled the story pretty poorly
in my opinion which had been keeping me
away pretty effectively ever since
shadowlands which was the last expansion
but then they pulled the big one oh yeah
they thought to themselves you know what
who cares about the
you know what people actually like
dragons then they looked at us players
and said hey kid You like dragons be a
dragon and damn it now I'm a dragon I've
always been a pal M though because
paladins are the only real choice in
this game so I've enjoyed bringing my
Paladin my new dragon dude and some
other Tunes to max level I've enjoyed it
for the most part I'll admit though I
don't really care about the main story
currently and I take some issue with
Blizzard's repeated laziness which you
can see while playing the game for
instance on the new new dragon people
they refuse to make all the armor appear
on their characters because I don't know
it would just look too awkward or take
too much time to animate and they
randomly switch between hand animated
cutcenes and just in-game emote cutcenes
which is jarring at best but I digress
on the other hand you can fly dragons
with physics based momentum now which is
really cool so that already spices my
apple cider but what really roasts my
chestnuts is World of Warcraft classic
currently they're on the old Wrath of
the Lich King expansion which in my
opinion and a lot of other players
opinions is Peak World of Warcraft I
have two characters currently at level
70 I know that's not max level but if
you can't understand how big of an
achievement that is then you you you
just need to play WoW classic okay in
addition to World of Warcraft though I
also picked up Hearthstone again this
year not that I'm much good at it and by
that I mean I'm amazing at it once again
I aain a paladin because that is the
only real choice in any game but I also
dabble with my warlock Druid priest and
death knight decks from time to time
what can I say me and blizzard we go way
back actually I uh I wish we could go
way back to when I was a kid and didn't
know about all the ethical no NOS that
have been going on in their
workplace but hey all I can say is one I
want Justice for everybody who was
wronged two their CEO is out in about 4
days and three it's Christmas so we're
moving on I wonder what game I'll talk
about next must have been a pretty
wonderful game to have made it on this
list right
Super Mario Brothers Wonder kind of came
out of the blue and I don't know a
better example of that than Mario's
latest wonderful PowerUp the elephant
fruit which turns whoever eats it into
you guessed it an elephant it's every
kid's dream I can only imagine how that
conversation happened in Nintendo's
creative room everybody was sitting
around talking about new level designs
and you know how Bowser's going to get
around to stealing Princess Peach yet
again in this game and then one guy in
the back was just like hey what if Mario
turned into an elephant
and then everyone just goes dead silent
and stares at the guy and
goes you're a genius you know that
you're a freaking genius because
seriously any of the characters can grab
one of these elephant fruits and become
elephanz and there's just no expounding
on it Nintendo really said they're
elephants now deal with it truth be told
in the first few days that I was playing
Super Mario Brothers wonder I loved its
charm as is pretty typical with Nintendo
games I mean I didn't know that I needed
wonderful piranha plants in my life
until now or the wondrous new badges
that enhance your character's move set
but I was still left to wonder to myself
why it got a game of the year nomination
especially above other games that also
released this year it was good but was
it that good it wasn't until I was about
halfway through the game that all the
Wonder really started to just hit me
this game is chalk full of more secrets
than my underwear drawer Each of which
feel really good to discover and work
through and after I had beaten Bowser
and unlocked all the super hard Secret
World levels I wandered aloud to myself
oh so that's why it got nominated if you
haven't played it yet do it seriously
why why are you hurting yourself by not
playing it just do it I played a lot of
indie games this year too like
phasmophobia which didn't exactly
released this year but still has a fern
grip around my Jingle Bells you hunt
ghosts in haunted houses with friends I
mean what's not to love but in a similar
vein there's another indie game that
just came out recently that I'm
currently obsessed with called lethal
company and I know you heard about
lethal company and for very good reason
it has that similar phasmophobia esque
Vibe of achieving a common goal with
friends all the while trying to not die
a horrible death at the hands of various
monsters but seriously it's got nine
maps called moons to explore each time
loading in with a randomly generated
facility to explore to keep you on your
tippy toes filled with randomly
generated and placed loot littered with
randomly generated monsters Each of
which have to be countered differently
and the game has
lore huzz a it's new it's trendy it's
fun it's cheap it's multiplayer it's
scary it's goofy but best of all it's
[Music]
Jolly so do yourself a flavor go pick it
up seriously go pick it up and I did
play more games than just that this year
but they were mostly all games from
years past like Elden ring or project
play time or gench and impact so I
digress also I'm out of hot chocolate
but what did you play this year what did
you enjoy what did you less than enjoy
let old Bandit know in the comments
below and while I made this video as a
Christmas gift to you you could give a
Christmas gift to me by liking the video
or subscribing to stick around for lots
more or following me on my social medias
that would really put the Chris in my
cringle but above everything of course
and as always thank you for watching
thank you for 20 23 here's to 2024 happy
holidays and I'll see you next time ho
ho ho Merry
[Music]
Christmas
y